This is introduction to New
Testament history and literature.
My name is Dale Martin. I've been
teaching here at Yale for 10 years now.
I also was a Grad student here in the
80s in the religious studies department.
I then left taught one year at
Rhodes College in Memphis, Tennessee.
Then I taught 11 years at Duke and got
in love with their basketball team,
but then I came to Yale in 1999 this is
a course that introduces you to the New
Testament literature,
but also the history of other material
from the very first 100 years or so of
early Christianity.
The first question you need to ask
yourself is why do you want or why you
thinking about taking this course? Why is
do you want to study the New Testament?
What is the New Testament
and why should you study it?
The first obvious answer there are a lot
of people would give is because I'm a
Christian or I believe that New Testament
scripture and therefore I'm here to
learn more about this document.
That is scripture for me in my church.
The problem with that answer is
before you say something is scripture.
You have to say,
why is it scripture?
For whom is it scripture and what
does that mean? And in Christianity,
when you call the Bible scripture,
what that means is that you're going
to listen to it for the word of God.
You're expecting somehow the holy spirit
or God to communicate to you and to
your church,
into your community through this document.
But script the text of the
Bible isn't scripture in itself.
It's only scripture to a community
of people who take it as scripture.
The text itself,
any text is not itself holy writing.
That's what scripture means towards.
It actually just means
written stuff from the Latin.
But we take it to mean holy writings,
sacred writing,
but the writing itself is not holy. It's
only holy to people who take it as holy.
Now, the problem is we're at Yale
College. This is not a holy place.
I know they might've told you that when
you came, but you've learned differently,
haven't you? Uh, this
is also not a church.
So what does it mean to read the New
Testament as scripture is not something
we're going to really pursue in this
class because this is not a religious
community.
So one of the things that if you're
here to learn about the new testament
because it's scripture, the class may
disappoint you from that point of view.
Somebody else might say,
uh Oh,
I'm here because this is a foundational
document for Western civilization and I
want to know something about the Bible.
There are probably some more seats over
here are some of you need to can go sit
on the steps over there if you
need to make your way around,
can they get behind you? But
what does that mean? Also,
if you say that the Bible
is a foundational document
for Western civilization,
does that mean you can't really get
along in Western civilization unless you
know something about the Bible and think
about that isn't a knowledge of lots of
other things, much more important for how
you get along in Western civilization.
Then knowing that the new testament,
for example,
it's much more important
to know about cars.
It'd be actually much more valuable for
you to know how to fix your car than it
is to know about the New Testament,
right?
If you're going to getting
along in Western civilization
or how to use computers
or sexual technique or how
to speak other languages,
there are all kinds of things that it
might be very useful for you to know as an
inhabitant of Western civilization and
the New Testament you might find out
would rank kind of down on the list of
those kinds of things. Besides that,
okay, let's take a quiz first. Got a
piece of paper. This is your first exam.
This will determine your grade
for the rest of the semester.
Tell me if this is in the new testament
is in the Bible or is not in the Bible.
All right. Just a yes or no question
you. All you need is 10 places to write,
yes or no. You could even
abbreviate and put wire in first.
Which of these things are in the Bible?
The Immaculate Conception,
the Immaculate Conception. Now, you
may not know anything about the Bible.
If you don't know, just kind
of guess. Just make a guess,
but I'm not actually going to grade.
These is the immaculate conception,
something that's in the
Bible to this quotation.
Love bears. All things, believes
all things, hopes all things,
endures all things is that
quotation in the Bible.
Love bears all things, believes
all things, hopes all things,
endures all things.
Three at Jesus's birth,
three wise men or three
kings visited the baby.
Jesus is that in the Bible
for this quotation from each according
to his ability to each according to his
need,
from each according to his ability
to each according to his need. Fifth,
the doctrine of the
trinity is in the Bible.
Sixth this quotation, you are Peter, and
upon this rock I will build my church.
Seven Peter founded the church in
Rome and the Bible not in the Bible.
Peter founded the church in Rome.
Make a guess. Eight after his death,
Jesus appeared to his disciples in
Jerusalem. Is that in the Bible?
After his death, Jesus appeared
to his disciples in Jerusalem.
No talking with your neighbor
night after his death,
Jesus appeared to his disciples
in Galilee. After his death,
in Galilee, 10th and last.
Okay. Peter was martyred by
being crucified upside down.
Oh, hard one. Okay, let's go back.
Number one is the macula conception in
the Bible. How many people think so? Yes.
How many people say no,
it's not in the Bible.
Somebody tell me what the immaculate
conception is. You might know.
Yes. Mary's conception, Mary's conception.
It doesn't refer to the
miraculous conception of Jesus.
That's what often people think. C,
one of the things about these courses,
you'll learn a lot about
the Bible and Christianity,
but the most important thing is you
learn cocktail party conversation tips.
So think about, you know, you really
want to impress that girl you're with,
you know,
hey,
did you know that a lot of people think
that the immaculate conception refers to
the conception of Jesus?
It doesn't.
There are firstly the conception of
Mary as being without original sin.
Immaculate means without stain.
So at first, the conception
of Mary by her mother,
Anna. Uh, without that,
the according to tradition,
without being Trent, without original
sin being transferred to marry.
And that's because according
to Roman Catholic tradition,
then she could transmit the birth
of Jesus without original sin. Also.
Now that's not actually in the Bible
is part of Roman Catholic doctrine.
It's something that
Protestants don't accept,
but a lot of people think it's one in
the d in the Bible or a lot of people
confuse it with the morass,
miraculous conception of Jesus,
which is in the Bible and the Gospel of
Luke and the Gospel of Matthew Second,
uh, love bears all things believes
all things, hopes all things,
endures all things.
How many people say it's in the Bible?
Can anybody tell me where? Come on.
There's got be some funds in here.
First Corinthians 13, good Sunday
school of Education. Three,
three wise men are kings, visited
the baby, Jesus and the Bible,
not in the Bible.
How many people say it's not in the Bible?
You say it's not in the Bible.
Why? I guess you have no idea.
It's not in the Bible.
It's true that Wiseman or kings did visit
Jesus in the Gospel of Eh, of Gospel,
of Matthew. But it's only tradition
that says that it's three of them.
Why was the tradition developed that there
were three kings have visited the, uh,
the manger of Jesus? Yes. Yes.
The gifts. There are three gifts,
gold, frankincense, and myrrh.
And so tradition just said, well,
if there are three gifts, there must be
three kings. So that's why we have that.
But it's not in the Bible.
This quotation from each according to
his ability to each according to his need
in the Bible. Raise your hand, not
in the Bible. Raise your hand. Ah,
couldn't trick you. Does anybody know
where it is from? Yes. Yes. Marks.
It's from marks,
but a lot of people will hear that
and I think that's from the Bible.
The doctrine of the trinity in the Bible,
not in the Bible.
Okay. Why are all you people saying the
doctor's attorneys not in the Bible?
That's usually a real good one.
Somebody explaining why the doctrine,
the trinity is not in the Bible.
You're right. It's not in the Bible.
I thought it was thought up by
the church to explain the paradox.
Exactly.
The doctrine of the trinity is a doctrine
that developed post New Testament
Times to explain why Christians
were worshiping Jesus.
And the Holy Spirit also is
divine. So they, the doctor,
the trinity developed in the
later centuries afternoon tea.
Now some people will say,
at least the doctrine of the trinity
has hinted at in the Bible and that the
later church was correct to read the
New Testament too, to support it.
And that may be,
I'll be right theologically,
but red historically it's not in the
Bible. Uh, you are my, you are Peter.
And upon this rock, I will build my
church. How people say it's in the Bible.
How many people say it's not in the Bible?
It's in the Bible says in Matthew 16,
seven Peter founded the church in Rome
is in the Bible. Y'All are insurance.
Is it not in the Bible? Uh, more people
say it's not in the Bible. You're right,
is not in the Bible.
It's part of tradition.
And it's very strong part of Christian
tradition. But it's not in the Bible.
After his death, Jesus appeared to his
disciples in Jerusalem, in the Bible.
Raise your hand. A few people,
not in the Bible. You're wrong.
It is in the Bible. It's in the gospel
of Luke and acts. After his death,
Jesus appeared to his disciples in
Galilee. Is that in the Bible? Yes.
Some of you say yes.
Not In the Bible.
Anybody brave enough to say it's not
in the Bible. It is in the Bible.
It's in the Bible Incident,
the gospel of Matthew,
but now notice the gospel of
Matthew is we'll talk about later.
Has Jesus appears to his
disciples only in Galilee,
not in Judea and the
gospel of Luke and acts.
Have Jesus appeared to his disciples
only in Judea but not in Galilee.
Ah,
that's an interesting problem.
We will have to get to at
some point 10th and last.
Peter was martyred by being crucified
upside down in the Bible are not in the
Bible, in the Bible, not in the
Bible. The Not in the Bible is habit.
It's not in the Bible, but it's a very
important part of Christian tradition.
Now that I did a little quiz.
These are all things that a lot of
people out there would say, oh yeah,
that's in the Bible or it sounds like
something that should be in the Bible,
right?
Most of them aren't.
Or about half of them I think are
not in the Bible and yet they're very
important for the history
of Western civilization.
They're important for
people's conceptions.
They're important for the history of art.
How many paintings are there of Peter
Crucified upside down or depictions in
western art.
So it's very important for someone to
know that there is an important tradition
about Peter being crucified upside down,
but it's not a part of the new testament.
It illustrates again, uh, this,
this idea that how much of this ancient
text is an important for you to know on
its own terms,
in its historical context in the first
century or how it was important for you
to know in the way it's been
interpreted for the last 2000 years.
And what I am telling you
is kind of contrary to the
way I'm going to teach this
course.
I'm actually advertising against myself
and there'll be fewer of you here next
time. Right. Contrary to
way outreach discourse,
which is more on the history of the
first century of these documents and how
they,
what they meant in the first century.
The sometimes the most important thing
about the Bible is its impact on the
later history and that's something that
we'll talk about from time to time in
the class, but it's something
you'd get more out of. For example,
if you studied art history class,
if you studied literature class that
talked about some of these issues in later
European times, we could, I could
illustrate with a lot more other things.
For example,
if I said,
what do most people about believe about
what happens to you after you're dead
and you'd get lots of different
ads or you're dead like rover,
you're dead all over.
Some people say you go to heaven.
Some people have all kinds of
different things. Most if I said,
what do you think Christian religious
people believe about what happens to you
after you're dead? In other words
where his aunt Martha at the funeral,
while she's up with the arms of
Jesus, she's safe in heaven. She,
her soul is there.
Most people would say that Christians
are religious people believe in the
immortality of the soul and that is part
of a good bit of Christian doctrine.
That again is not something that's
in the Bible really. Uh, so,
and it's not even the best interpretation
of official Christian Orthodoxy
according to official Christian Orthodoxy,
the form of,
of your afterlife existence is
the resurrection of the body.
That's what the new testament talks about.
Either the resurrection of the flesh
or the resurrection of the body.
That's contrary to what most people
kind of assume is what people believe.
The point about this and where do they
get the idea of the immortality of the
soul, much more from Plato.
So again, it raises the issue.
If you want to know more about the
most influential aspects for Western
civilization,
would it be better for you to take an
entire semester on Plato than it would on
the New Testament?
I'm saying it might actually,
the ironic fact is because the new
testament is considered more important by
people.
There are a whole lot more people who
take my new testament classes then go over
to the classics department
and take a course in Plato.
I'm not sure that's the way it should be,
but that's the way it is.
What this does is it brings up
this issue of why are you here?
What do you hope to get out of this
course and I want you to understand the
method that will pursue in the course.
My point is to get you to see that
when we study this text in this class,
we're not going to be
studying it necessarily as
scripture as the word of God.
We're not going to be studying it
necessarily for how important it was for
medieval and early modern literature.
For example.
We're going to look at what it
meant in the first century. In fact,
what I'm going to try to do is get you
to come at the new testament from the
outside.
I've been teaching this stuff for 20
years and I think I tend to find two basic
kinds of students who shot my classes for
the new testament introduction course.
One of them are the kinds of students
who grew up in a religious household.
They went to church.
They may have even taken a lot of Sunday
school and so they feel like they know
these texts for at least a Sunday
school at Church kind of point of view.
And some ways they kind of feel like,
okay,
I know what the New Testament is and I
already know sort of what I think about
it.
There are other people who come to these
classes who grew up in a nonreligious,
uh, uh, context. They know nothing about
this. They've never read the Bible.
And they come in and they think,
well,
I'm taking it because I don't know
anything about it. But oddly enough,
because they've been
raised in our society,
they still actually come at this text
with some kind of pre knowledge of the
text. They have a conception of what the
Bible is. They have a conception of what,
who Jesus is,
who Paul is.
And so they're coming at the text already
with some kind of familiarity with the
topic,
at least in there in a popular conception.
Now the reason that is true is because
we live in a post Christian culture and
both aspects of that
termers are important.
It's post Christian in the sense that you,
it's hard to live in America without
having some kind of exposure to
Christianity and without seeing its
influence on our society, on our politics,
on our culture and our art
and that sort of thing.
But it's also post Christian because you
can no longer assume in this culture,
especially in a multi valence
poly, uh, Ho polyethylene,
poly ethnic, ethnic, poly,
ethnic, uh, situation like Yale,
that everybody here is
going to be Christian.
So we were in this kind of situation where
we have the hangovers of Christianity
still occupying the culture without
necessarily knowing a lot about it.
So I'm going to ask you to come at the
new testament though from the outside.
If you feel like you
know something about it,
put those aside for the moment
because when, when we do,
the class will be trying to get you to
see this document as if for the first
time to see early Christianity
completely as if for the first time.
So let's do a little practice run
through this for come with me now.
Open up your new testament is you're just
going to look at it and we're going to
go through a rush little survey
through the New Testament.
How would it strike you if
you knew nothing about it,
if you'd never heard of it before?
If you open up the covers of
this book for the first time,
the very beginning is the gospel
of Matthew and it starts like this.
The book of the origin or the genesis
is the Greek word of Jesus Christ,
son of David, son of Abraham.
Abraham had a son named Isaac.
Isaac had a son named Jacob.
Jacob had Judah and his brothers.
Judah had fairies and Zara from Tamar.
And you know how this goes, right?
This is the begats. The famous begets
that. Start the the gospel of Matthew.
So and so begat so and so begat so and so.
And it goes on like this for sentences
and sentences. And as a modern person,
you're going, what is this? What,
what, what's going on with this?
And then you get to the
birth narratives in Matthew,
the stories of the baby Jesus. If you
lived during the time of Matthew himself,
all of this stuff would seem fairly
familiar to the idea that famous,
that kings would come from
far off and see a star.
And that meant that the birth
of someone great had been born.
This is actually part of propaganda
culture of the ancient world.
If you are an ancient person and you
picked up the gospel of Matthew and you
heard these stories about these kings
from the east following a star and
arriving and finding this baby, uh,
that would sound, oh, you know, okay,
this is gonna be somebody great. This is
telling you that this is him, his self,
a king or somebody. Great.
So it would, it would be,
it would sound familiar to
you in the ancient world.
Then you'd go on and read the
rest of the gospel of Matthew.
It's a story of a man who
travels around giving speeches,
sometimes talking to people or teaching.
He's exercising demons,
performance, a few miracles.
He heals people. And again,
to us in the modern world,
if you didn't already had some,
some exposure to religious narratives
like this, that would sound odd.
In the ancient world,
actually it would've sounded familiar
because there were other stories of other
kinds of teachers who'd healed and
exercise demons and perform miracles.
That was not an uncommon way to talk about
someone who was supposed to be great,
but then you get to the next book in the
New Testament, the gospel of mark. Well,
it's kind of the same story. It's shorter.
There's less, fewer teachings in it,
but so why do you have the second
chapter of this book retail?
The same story that the first chapter of
the book told the Gospel of [inaudible].
Same thing. You get to the gospel
of John. John's kind of different,
it sounds different. There's
a different style, but again,
it's the same story of this same guy.
Why do you have four different chapters
of this book? All telling the same story.
That's odd in itself from our point
of view or it should look odd to us.
Then you get to the acts of the apostles.
Now we're back on more familiar ground.
It starts off like the gospel of Luke
is because it's written by the same guy
who wrote the gospel of Luke and in
fact it starts off with a paragraph that
kind of encapsulates the way it was,
how the gospel of Luke ended,
you know like TV shows last time on er,
and this is the way the acts of the
apostle begin last time and Luke it into
this way. Now we're going to take
up our heroes at their next point.
Then it starts sounding like a Greco
Roman novel and I have to tell you
something about novels. In the ancient
world, there were Greek and Latin novels,
Greek novels.
Usually we're about a man and a woman,
young rich who see each other and fall
madly in love and passionately wanted one
another and they might get married to,
they might not get married,
but they don't get to consummate
their [inaudible]. Instead,
one of them gets kidnapped
or has to go off to war,
are captured by pirates and she's taken
over by pirates and sold into slavery
and she goes all the way
around the Mediterranean and
the young man follows her
chapter after chapter after chapter.
They always almost connect
and almost get to have sex.
And then no there she's bought by somebody
else and taken it into another slave
job or he's captured by pirates.
And so the whole novel is them chasing
each other around the Mediterranean with
shipwrecks and battles and miracles
and God's intervening and all kinds of
stuff. And that's what the acts of
the apostle kinds of looks like.
It looks like an ancient Greek novel,
except it lacks the one thing
every good Greek novel had sex.
The acts of the apostles doesn't have sex.
You might be disappointed there,
but you also have other things that
the novels don't have such as the Holy
Spirit being the main
actor for the whole thing.
But notice that would look kind of
familiar to you in the ancient world.
It definitely looks odd to you in the
modern world if you don't read it as the
Bible and if you just
read it as literature,
and we also realized that the
acts of the apostles is ms titled,
it's not the acts of the apostles is
the axe basically a Paul and Paul is not
considered an apostle by the guy
who wrote the acts of the apostles.
This is another little clue here.
We will learn this semester the titles of
most of the books in the New Testament.
We're not put there by their authors.
They were put there by later Christian
scribes. This will be very important.
Then you get to the letters of,
and it's,
is it strange that most of the New
Testament are actually letters?
They're not like modern letters. There
are quite a bit like ancient letters.
They're usually addressed to groups
of people and they deal with sort of
philosophical sounding issues and
they'd give advice on group problems.
Then you get to the epistle to the Hebrews
or in what a better translation would
be the letter to the Jews.
What's odd about it is as you
read this epistle to the Hebrews,
you realize two things. Number one, it's
not a letter, it's actually a sermon.
In fact,
it doesn't even claim to be a letter.
It looks just like a sermon and you
realize this is not really addressed to
Jews.
It's,
it seems to be addressed to gentile
Christians to convince them that Jesus
provides for them a liturgy
that is superior to Judaism.
It's actually neither a letter
nor is it addressed to Jews.
This leads to an insight though by this
time when you're surveying your New
Testament, these letters seem
to be meant to be read out loud,
so what we'll, we'll ask this over
and over again in the semester.
What would it mean to re read this
letter out loud in a community,
not alone in your dorm room or
just by yourself in the library.
Then you get to first Peter.
It's written not to one place,
but it's a circular letter
meant to be circulated around.
Then you get to second and third John
Two letters that are written to the
elected lady and her children.
What does that mean?
Then finally you get to the
revelation of John the apocalypse.
The word revelation is just the Latinized
English version of the Greek word
apocalypse and the apocalypse
just means opening up revelation.
This document is really bizarre.
It's not like anything you've
confronted so far in the New Testament.
It starts off with a narrative about
a vision. This guy named John says,
I was on the island of Patmos.
I was in the Lord's Day.
I started having this vision and this
angel should've been. This all happened.
Then it has several letters,
seven different letters,
very short letters addressed to several
to seven different Christian churches
and then it goes into
this wild video game,
MTV style narrative of a heavenly
journey of this Guy John.
He goes up into the heavens. He
sees the Throne Room of God. He's,
he's weird kinds of beasts and animals
that have like their bodies of lambs,
but they've got horns and they're
bleeding all over the place.
It's a story of catastrophes.
It's a story of a cosmic battle between
forces of good and forces of evil is
like several installments of Star
Wars and finally it ends up with the
establishment of a new
world and a new city of God.
Now that's a long way.
That's the end of the New Testament.
That's a long way from the little baby
Jesus and the three kings in Matthew,
isn't it? But the new testament includes
all that kind of diverse literature,
27 different books written anywhere from
the year 50 to the year one 50 so a 100
year period of time that these
books were probably written in.
They have different points of
view, different situations,
different theologies,
different genres.
They use confusing inhouse language.
I'll point out that in house language
throughout the semester and we'll talk
about how to be,
how it should be interpreted and these,
these texts almost defy interpretation
by a modern person unless you have
guidance from a historian
and expert like Moi,
let's do this little trick again instead
of looking at the documents from the
outside,
let's look at what would
an early Christian Church
look like if you would just
stumble upon them.
Little imagination.
Let's pretend that you're a seamstress.
You work in a clothing shop in the city
of Corinth in Greece in the year 56 a
guy next door to you named Fred and
works in a leather factory next door.
He has just joined a new club and he's
going to tell you all about it. First,
they don't meet in the daytime.
They meet either early before light
in da at dawn or after dark at night.
There's only enough of them to
fill a decent size dining room,
but they call themselves the town meeting.
You're not sure what they
do at these meetings.
They don't appear to worship any
God or goddess that you can see.
They use the term God sometimes,
but this God doesn't have a name.
And that's very bizarre to you.
Remember you're pretending you're a
Greek person living in the year 56 in
Corinth. In fact, these people don't
look like they believe in gods at all.
They looked like atheists.
They have a very high respect
for a criminal Jew who
led some kind of guerrilla
war and was executed along
ago somewhere in Syria.
Fred says though,
that this Jew is still alive somewhere.
In fact, Fred says that, that
you bought him though he didn't.
You didn't know that Fred was
even ever a slave. In fact,
you're pretty sure the
slave wasn't a slave.
So what does it mean that this guy
bought him at these town meetings?
They eat meals, which is not unusual since
most clubs in your society eat meals,
but they call them meals, the bosses
dinner, or sometimes the thank you.
Some people say they eat
human flesh at these dinners,
but you doubt that because for some
reason they seem to be all vegetarians.
You kinda doubt where the
vegetarians we eat human flesh.
Fred says that to get to initiate
new members into their Club,
they dip them naked and
then they get healthy.
Once you're in the club that called you
comrade and you have sex with anyone and
everyone because it doesn't matter
anymore whether you're a man or a woman.
In fact, they kind of figure
you're neither or both.
That's this new group.
Now,
I constructed that little picture out of
actual data from the New Testament and
what we have from writings about
ancient Christians. This was the way,
at least a good many number of ancient
people saw early Christian groups.
Every one of the little
details there I gave,
I won't unpack them off for
you now because it would
just be boring and we need
to move along,
but every one of those details comes
from some interpretation of a particular
Greek term that Christians used. For
example, I said this meal they have,
it's called the bosses dinner.
We call it the Lord's supper,
but the lord doesn't mean God necessarily.
It means your boss.
So the Lord's supper put back into normal
Greek language would be something like
the bosses dinner or I said they caught
the thank you Episcopalians call the
communion when they take it on Sunday,
the Eucharist,
which is just from the Greek word meaning
thanks. So all of these different,
the part about it doesn't matter
whether you're a man and woman.
Christians went around saying things like
in Christ there is no male and female,
what?
No male and female.
And some outsiders did interpret that
as meaning that these Christians seem to
kind of have sex with each other.
They call each other brother and sister.
And yet they're all talking
about love all the time.
They have meetings at night in the dark.
Yeah.
So there were all these rumors about
early Christian groups like this.
So a lot of these things that
I said they call you comrade.
Well Christians called each
other brother and sister.
But that wouldn't have been sort of normal
everyday way to talk about a stranger
in the ancient world.
It would sound somewhat odd like our
thinking that it would be somewhat,
you know, odd or communist or
something to call somebody comrade.
So the language that different early
Christians used about each other and for
themselves was sometimes
very common Greek language,
but sometimes it would have also sounded
strange and kind of in house to other
people.
In other words,
the Bible presents us with a very strange
world if we approach it without our
normal preconceptions, if we approach
it fresh and from the outside,
this is an ancient collection of
documents. It wasn't all put together. Uh,
right when they were,
when a written,
next time I'm going to actually talk
about how did these 27 different diverse
documents come to be included
in the New Testament?
That's the whole history of the Canon
and I'll talk about that in my next
section.
In fact,
a good bit of the history of Kush early
Christianity and the new testament
itself was to take what was a diverse
group of different people all somehow
being loyal to this guy.
They call Jesus,
but they weren't all the same and they
were in different geographical situations.
They had different beliefs and early
Christianity was an attempt to pull all
these things into one unified movement.
Some way to get some kind of
uniformity of belief and practice,
so this course is actually going to run
counter to that historical tendency to
make unity out of diversity.
What we're going to do is we're going to
take the new testament and we're going
to take the different writings and we're
going to take them apart and what were
the, one of the major themes of the
course will be the diversity of early
Christianity.
In fact,
the diversity of early Christianity's
is one of the ways I put it on the
syllabus.
We will look at all the different ways
Jesus was thought of to be either divine
or human or some combination of both.
We'll look at different ways that early
Christians dealt with the fact that this
movement seemed to come out of Judaism.
What does that mean? Where Jews, if not,
what does it mean? We are, we'll look
at all the different diversities,
how they treated women,
different ways that women, uh,
could take a place in this movement are
different ways that they treated slaves
and, and others, uh, servants
in their households. How,
how did they react to the politics?
How did they react to the
powerful Roman Empire?
We'll take all these different topics
at different points in the course and
we'll talk about the diverse ways that
early Christians reacted to these social
and cultural issues. And we'll read
the New Testament in light of that.
So what's going on is taking what is a
unity and pulling apart that unity to see
the diversity of this early Christian
movement and these documents.
And I'm going to pause for a minute and
let you ask questions or make comments
or throw things or whatever.
Don't be shy.
Yeah.
You get to talk at all about sort of
how the decisions were made to what
documents to include or
what documents do exclude.
Yes.
He's had asked if I was in talking about
how decisions were made about what to
include in the New Testament,
what not to include the basement
and we'll talk about that.
Actually the next lecture when I
talk about the history of the cannon,
why were some books,
there were a lot more early Christian
pieces of literature that we know of some
we're discovering all the
time the Gospel of Judas,
you may have read in the newspapers and
magazines that a new gospel of Judas has
just been published that uh,
some of them people at Yale actually
knew 20 years ago existed cause there was
shown to some people here but most
people didn't know about it and it was,
it's just been published
in English translation.
Why did the Gospel of Judas
not make it into the cannon?
We'll talk about those issues next time.
Yes sir.
Okay.
Are we going to go over the different
translations in which one's best?
We will raise the issue of translation
periodically. For example, uh,
when I talk about the
syllabus in just a moment,
I'm going to talk about what Bible you
should bring to class. And I recommend,
I did recommend one particular
study Bible to the bookstore to buy,
but I'm sort of hoping that not everybody
will bring that same translation of
the new testament because
sometimes I'll say, well,
this translation says this in the English.
Does anyone have a different translation?
And it particular points when there's
something important to about the different
translations, I'll bring that up and
I'll explain of everyone's thought.
That won't be sort of a major
lecture in its own right.
It's something that will
come up over and over again.
How does translation happen? How to
debates about translation get resolved?
Yes.
The Old Testament at all.
Either sort of how it really
Christians regarded or appropriate.
Am I going to talk about the Old
Testament all I will when it's relevant.
So for example,
a next time I will also talk a bit about
the Canon of the Old Testament and how
there are different decisions
about that from the New Testament.
I'll talk about how that,
why the Jewish Bible is different
from the Roman Catholic Bible,
even with regard to what they
consider the old testament. Um,
when we talk about Apocalyptic Cism
and the gospel of Mark and Judaism,
I'm actually gonna you have to read,
uh,
at least the last half of the book
of Daniel a from the old testament.
And the reason is because Daniel is an
older apocalyptic prophetic text that was
heavily influenced on
early Christian literature.
So there and I will give a lecture,
uh,
in about two more times on the history
of Judaism in this second temple period.
That is what Judaism look like
at the time of Jesus and Paul.
And that will necessitate
referring to the Hebrew Bible some.
So I will every once in a while, but
I'm not, I'm not going to know. I will,
for example,
talk about why did the gospel of Matthew
take this particular Hebrew Bible text
to be a prophecy about Jesus.
And we'll look back maybe and see how
that Biblical text would have looked in
its original context. But
so when, when it's relevant,
I will refer back to the Hebrew
Bible or the Old Testament.
And for those of you who are not aware,
uh,
what Christians call the Old Testament is
simply what Jews call the Hebrew Bible.
That basically refers
to the same document.
We just use different terms because
for the Jews, of course Hebrew.
Scripture is not old in the sense of past.
Say any other questions?
Yes.
We'll be talking some more legacies
of Bible on the later layers here.
Well, we were talking about the legacies
of the Bible in later literature,
not as much as I should and that's why
we at the very beginning of this lecture,
you may have come in a little bit late.
I said,
this course will concentrate on the
meaning of these texts in their early
historical context. Every once in a
while we'll bring up an issue of, well,
how has this been interpreted
over the centuries?
The one time you'll get this very
strongly is the one time where you go with
your discussion section. I'll talk about
the discussion sections in a moment.
You're expected to all go to the Yale Art
Gallery and go through the art gallery
with your discussion leader.
And then you'll do a lot of looking
at how our biblical themes and issues
portrayed in later art. And that may
bring up chances to talk about literature.
Also, if you want to bring up those
kinds of issues, pope feel free to,
but I'm going to concentrate in this
course on the meaning of these texts in
their earliest context.
Okay?
Anybody else? Questions?
Okay, look at your syllabus.
If you don't have a syllabus, um, are
there any extras back there? Okay,
well there you can find the
syllabus if you want to,
are some more right here
if anybody needs one. Um,
if you are a friend of yours wants to
see the syllabus after the class and you
don't have one,
it's on the Classes v two server so you
can go online and get the syllabus and
download it and print it.
Um,
one of the things I want to emphasize
that I'm not in size already is attendance
here in the lectures
is very much required.
You will be expected to
come to the lectures.
Just because this is a large electric
course doesn't mean you can skip the
lectures. Even if you're doing
the readings from the textbook,
you'll get stuff from my lectures
that you won't get elsewhere,
so you are required to come to the
lectures. The section leaders will,
once they get to know you,
they'll actually be looking to see
whether the people in their section are
missing a bunch of lectures and
I've asked them to take notes.
If you're missing a lot of lectures,
it could of it could affect your grade,
so please come to the lectures.
There are only three assignments to six
page papers that I'll explain how to do.
One is the next Jesus paper and you'll,
we'll spend a whole section discussion
talking about what we mean by exit Jesus
and teaching you how to do it.
Another paper will be a thematic paper
on some aspect of conflict among early
Christians such as Jews.
In the law are women,
our politics and in the
final there will not be,
there will never be a
sit down final in class.
Your final exam will be basically
one or two questions, uh,
that I'll give to you ahead of time.
You take it home and you write basically
like an eight page double spaced paper
on the question,
not doing research.
We don't want you to go run outside and
do research using the material you've
learned in class.
You'll be expected to answer some big
questions for the an eight page final
paper that you'll turn in at a date to
be assigned procedures for evaluation.
Important to make an a paper in my class,
like an a on a paper.
Not only does the paper have to be,
have the right answers and
fulfill the assignment,
it has to be written
elegantly and excellently.
Every Yale student has access
to free writing tutors.
I don't know if you realize
how rare that is in a college.
It certainly wasn't available to
me or most people of my generation,
but I know you have
access to writing tutors.
You can make an a in this class by writing
your papers far enough ahead of time
that you can take it to a writing tutor
and get the writing tutor to help you
get the style better and
then turn that version in.
That'll be much more
likely to give you an a.
If you write a paper that says all the
right things does all the right things,
and yet it's not well written,
it gets a B. If it's a c,
that means it's even worse written and
these and s or I mean you didn't really
fulfill the assignment. The texts
that I've ordered from the bookstore,
I'm fortunately there, I
just, I order them late,
but the labyrinth bookstore will
have the textbook by Bart Ehrman, uh,
that you can also go online
and just order it yourself.
The information is here on the syllabus.
I've ordered the Oxford annotated version
of the new revised standard version of
the Bible,
but like I say,
you're welcome to bring your up and
bring other translation, other versions.
When we use the term version of a Bible
that just means a different translation
of the Bible into English. So, uh,
if you want to use a revised standard
version that is other than the new revised
standards and that's fine, the
new International Bible, uh,
there are several other bibles,
translations that are acceptable.
I don't want you to use
the old translation such as
the King James version or
the Catholic.
Do a version.
Those have too many inaccuracies
because they're just too old.
I also would you rather than not,
you not use the sort of paraphrases
like the Living Bible, uh,
but if you want to use other
translations, that's fine. In fact,
sometimes that'll help us because
we'll compare translations.
Don't worry about, um,
discussion sections yet.
I'm not sure whether we'll use the
classes server to have you sign up for
discussion sections online or whether
we will do it the old fashioned way and
have you sign up, uh, on forms
that will give you here in class.
But we will organize you
into discussion sections.
There'll be a variety
of times you can choose.
So be there'll be options about when
your discussion section, we'll meet,
we'll try to make sure
everybody's scheduled was
accommodated and you'll either
meet on Thursdays or Fridays in discussion
sections and we'll organize those
sections closer to the end of the shopping
period when we have a better idea who
will be in here. As I said though,
the rest of the organization,
the class I think is
pretty well self evident.
The class is organized first to teach you
the methods of the historical critical
approach to the New Testament and
help you learn how to do those through
[inaudible] and historical study.
And then the second half of the class,
we turn our attentions to
more of these issues of,
of disagreement and debate within early
Christianity around issues such as
Judaism in the law, uh,
women's positions, politics,
and the interpretation of scripture.
So that's basically the semester.
Any other questions, comments, outbursts,
last chance? All right. If
you decide to take the course,
I will see you same place,
same time on Wednesday.